hey guys welcome to episode 7 of pokemon
gold logs just a quick update before we
start this Saturday the funds only
Niagara Falls is having a full-on event
and they invited us to vlog there's
going to be a giant pikachu caricature
artist and constant leurs around the
area for more information check the link
below and we hope to see you there
alright guys so we're here at heartland
trail as you can see there are a bunch
of books tops and I usually come here to
restock and poke balls I haven't seen
any rare Pokemon so far but we'll see
like I mean I've heard of people getting
starlix is from lures I don't let that
I'm through the location or if that's
just because like randomly a store like
spot though so I'm here today with Anna
Mac and our friend Martina and we're
going to be going to port deluzy but
here we're just gonna pick up a book
balls first Ricky and I exploring guys
couldn't resist the tree house it's not
really a tree house but it's kind of a
tree house do you like it yeah I guys
amazing place beautiful place and
definitely if you're here if your noggin
Falls check it out and you know leave
something there's a donation box keep it
going you know it's a sick idea just
conserving nature conserving this forest
and we don't have enough green space
these days i love i love the whole
premise all right shut out the heartland
alright guys so we're at port deluzy i'm
showing you guys the map right now a lot
of focus tops and a little while ago
seeing a lot of water pokemon Astarte
popped up i'm hoping to definitely get
some dirty knees yeah like i should we
heard from some of you guys that poor
deluzy it's about 20 minute drive from
Niagara Falls where we live and we heard
that it's a hot spot for water water
pokemon including some really cool ones
like slowpokes and dirty knees so we'll
see if we can find anything cool and if
we do we'll let you know
so we've been seeing Magikarp so full
popped up I've caught them in census
this is a great place using sense now I
probably go eat there's an awesome view
there and there's also poke stops we're
going to learn it see what else we can
get and we'll update you guys yeah and
we're just enjoying this nature and this
wildlife like check out these ducks Hey
duck alright guys we're just chilling
here now we're we learn it up we got
incense going hoping some cool water
profile pop up at the meantime we'll do
some evolutions while we're waiting for
the food first ones poliwag it has an
awesome Ivy's
so let's hope it becomes an awesome all
around see sort of poliwhirl 750 so
let's see what CP the poliwrath is going
to be i'm going to guess around 1450
thought I don't expect
what about these these guys want a small
fight again today because
full far right circle I didn't lucky I
get all 14
ice-watch not the best of all set but
hopefully the next one will be better
we popped out like the egg
but I wasn't recording any of that
really we're just play Molly rod is a
big deal also okay now we're gonna do
this gloom which is Ivy's ninety percent
so insanely good and let's hope this
time it has the idea of Musa
this is my third goal both of the other
previous ones had razor leaf and boom
blast so this one's the best I visa had
so far without the best boo set that
would be sick so first of all acid
second move peddle blizzard so still not
that good but a lot to keep trying if
anything for Margo is a game of patience
yeah yeah guys this pretty slick place I
got a saved weird we got all the word
here I got stops over in a lower
delicious food nice nature by the water
and free Wi-Fi so I no more could you
ask for gender game the password I guess
we're going back to Niagara Falls just
hunt leatherby's is very hot weather the
leather very it's it's all weather too
though and we're just yeah
edimax base sweaty up your coffee your
sweaty room we're also I've lighted the
cars the car is psycho it pulls the door
of the world anyways so yeah guys we
found like some magic herbs little folks
slowpoke so I dogs that sounds really
good for water pokemon yeah we got some
good water pokemon um so far like it has
really been better than a different
islands which will go to later today it
but it's been alright and we're way
closer to getting a gyarados so less
than 50 more to go alright guys being
para right here and we're at dufferin
islands we just caught a dratini and
ellora which is like the first time I've
ever seen something like that and which
is sick um we could try to get a bunch
more magic carbs you know maybe even do
the careless evolution today hopefully
what do you think do you think we will
you might I won't yeah I might that's
what's important that's what people
going so I don't have my camera with me
but clefairy 827 CP I've never seen
anything like this like 702 or something
was the highest i've seen before so we
got rise we ever got Ultra Ball I
hopefully we catch it like I can't I
came in a badge of what kind of a fable
this will be at least 16 on come on
don't like
oh we got this we gotta get up we did it
perfectly everything's awesome Luhrmann
Wow like I feel like is it gonna be four
thousand power up like yeah at least ya
guys it certainly caught the interest
all right can't wait to evolve this one
yo I can't believe it I can't believe I
dragonair from incense holy holy holy we
gotta get this we got to get this old
man old man we're just walking around
dufferin Islands insane insane oh all we
got to get this door run don't run Oh
God pop them right away relax box okay
it's all good so good Tara's watching
just Robbie a little jealous very
jealous called god this is insane like
I've
oh it's why don't know how to hit it oh
come on come on don't run don't run go
run whoo all right guys this this looks
like it's a bad as hard to catch as a
dragon knight so let's hope it does run
away like it's definitely prettier than
dragonite but
so hard to throw it far like it's
unbelievable such a pretty Pokemon come
on 1 2 3 we got out oh man guys that's
all amazing you Pokemon plus we're gonna
be able to now power up or Dragonite
rather than worrying about evolving a
dragon air amazing amazing and an egg
whoo Sarah what did you get that what's
the etiquette of you coffee Haley
getting mala coughing now in save Oh
amazing amazing poké puffs oh alright
guys we found the file Magikarp we need
and now go try to catch it will see
one-handed let's see if I can do it
slider bees
look if we've that dragon at all that's
dragging their oh oh let's get it come
on
yes yes 400 it's been a long road but we
got it we did had special thanks to pair
up for getting her blush out what I
needed her to so good morning guys last
I was insane we got the dragon air and
we got a poliwrath also and we got
enough for a gyarados so today we're
gonna do some crazy evolutions and also
we just now we were gonna stop playing
we're watching the office and then
Pikachu mopped up what to look for the
Pikachu I got actually my strongest
beauty ever in the process and then
thanks to para as well I actually did
find the Pikachu's won't see what he is
gonna be beautiful morning today before
Eon all right good start let's start
I've carried here with me Tara what do
you think it's gonna be
hydro pump guys 2024 CP with hydro pump
oh my god I could not have been better
that's insane Wow Wow guys that could
not have gone better my strongest needy
ever turns into a pory out with the best
most possible Wow all right and good ivs
Wow okay guys and at the moment of truth
what you've all been waiting for
Magikarp all right I told you guys last
episode that will get it soon and me and
Tara worked her butt off last night to
get enough magic harp this one's awesome
amazing I knees that's perfect attack
perfect defense now let's see who this
insane
we'll simply elit there is definitely
one of the coolest oaklawn out there and
strongest new pokedex edition of course
1745 not good Wilson don't but only 400
more canvas plus the before now makes up
for it anyways wow this episode was
unbelievable guys we got five brand new
Pokemon this episode which is crazy at
this level we got Polly rock wheezing
sam / dragonair gyarados not to mention
the best Eevee evolution ever I also
started to power up some pokemon like
nidoqueen vaporeon and dragonite now
usually I recommend only using startups
on the big ones already a good CP but I
almost never find Ragini's so dragon
knights and accept my squad is looking
amazing and i can't wait for saturday
till next time see you space cowboys
you